hey guys this is vadim with maxtec and
this is my sister
angelica and welcome to another unbiased
camera comparison except this time we're
taking a look at
mid-range smartphones like the iphone 12
the galaxy s20 fe and of course the
pixel 5 these are all around 700
to 800 now you might be wondering how
is this an unbiased camera comparison
well
our brother max actually took a bunch of
photos on all three of these phones
he put them all together and we have no
idea which phone was taken on which
smartphone in fact we haven't even
seen these photos yet we have our papers
and our pens ready go ahead and play
along get a paper and a pen too
and let us know your results in the
comments let's start with the first set
of images
alright so i could instantly tell that
the one in the center is extremely
saturated the one on the left looks very
dull so i don't like that i think i'm
going with the one on the right because
it's a good middle ground and i can see
a lot of detail in the trees
uh the first thing that i notice is that
the shot in the middle
it's very dark there's a lot of crushing
like in the trees you lose a ton of
detail other than that i really like it
but because of that i think i have to go
with the right one as well
oh s20fe not bad first point
for that one let's move on okay so we
have some selfies
whoa okay i think i like the one on the
right instantly look at that you can see
his beard all that detail
and it's very balanced the other two
they kind of like crush the details he
has like bags
definitely the one on the right you can
see so much more detail there's a lot of
crushing on the other ones where the
right one like brings them up like his
eyes there's a huge difference in like
all the beard detail
looks like that was the iphone 12 yep
the iphone 12 12 megapixel interesting
compared to 32 on the s28
on the pixel 5. not bad alright moving
on to a detail shot this looks to be
a close-up and here honestly i think i'm
gonna go with the one on the left
because the one in the center looks a
little bit
blown out i think i do like how like
everything is blurred out in the middle
one but when you look at the detail of
the veins
it does not seem as detailed as the one
on the left so i agree
okay iphone 12 wow surprising not that
bad
all right moving on we have a portrait
shot
so just looking here i think the one in
the center
has more detail like in her coat and i
kind of like the colors the one on the
right looks very
dark to me i don't really like that i
really like all of these shots
but to be honest yeah the one in the
center does look the best
iphone 12 again it's killing it all
right moving on we have another selfie
shot this is not a portrait or anything
like that
he says hit space to play so it's a
video so
i think stabilization is what he's
looking at
all right to me it looks like the one in
the center is more stabilized
let's see i like the colors the best too
the one on the left just it's
doesn't have that much detail yeah oh
look at that
nice so you're getting more hdr
in the center as well compared to the
other two
and i think there's more balanced colors
and detail
yeah there's still a lot of crushing on
the other two as well like in his hair
and his clothes
yep that's true okay iphone 12 what's
going on
so far none for the pixel 5 only one for
the s20
iphone 12 is killing it so with this one
right out of the gate the one on the
left
looks like it's just a little bit soft
almost like it's blurry it's kind of
flat
the one in the center and the right they
both look very good
except the colors on the right are kind
of
red-ish i don't know if that's how they
were i think the one in the center
is the winner what do you think i yeah i
agree again yeah man come on
hey s20 fe finally we gotta have a
different one i don't know what happened
with the iphone 12 but
s20fe right there look at that
got a nice tesla right here all right so
what do you think
out of these i think i like the one on
the right the most the one in the center
isn't like nearly as it's not really
ultra wide
it's pretty yeah this is using the
ultrawide lens yeah and then the one on
the left is very very blown out
the one in the center a little bit as
well but the one on the right definitely
holds the most detail
i think the one on the right again we
keep agreeing with each other iphone 12
man this is gonna sound biased but yeah
we haven't seen these photos yet and the
iphone 12 is killing it
another video hit space to play okay
what do we got
oh man this is tough a lot of flaring on
the left
there's a lot of flaring on the left oh
the center looks good right that's that
was what i noticed instantly the center
looks really good one of the center
looks the one on the right it looks a
little bit too
cool i don't know like the stabilization
sucks yeah the sky doesn't really
pop as much it looks kind of flat so i'm
going with the center me too
for sure iphone 12 again
what in the world that one was by far
better than the others
all right we got another selfie looks
like this is a very tough situation
the one on the left is instantly out
look look at the building it's blown out
definitely don't want that these two
look pretty good i don't know i think i
like the one on the left
the most even though it is a little bit
blown out
just because it's way more balanced like
the other these other two
the building isn't blown out but you
have to sacrifice max
like he's just so so dark it looks weird
yeah that's a good point honestly i kind
of like
the one in the center because you have
some i don't know if that's natural blur
but i kind of like it even though his
face you would want wax contrast you
would want that in
i don't know i don't know it's a tough
one this one just looks kind of
weird and flat i'm going with this i'm
going with the center okay
so iphone 12 on the left s20 in the
middle okay not bad
i don't want those i don't want those in
my phone all right looks like this is a
portrait shot i think yeah what do you
think these are all
very similar the blur in the middle one
is so different compared to the other
two
i think i definitely like the one on the
right the most you like that one better
yeah okay yeah i i honestly agree with
you because the one in the center i
think it has too much blur so you
it seems fake yeah you can't even tell
that it's a tree it's kind of weird
and then the one on the left there's so
much detail that's crushed in there
yeah it's a little bit blown out like in
the side of the house here too so
right again iphone 12. oh come on
all right so it looks like we have a
tough dynamic range shot
there's like no flaring on the right one
except for like one little
spot that's true i'm definitely going
with the right i mean like the left is
blown out like crazy on the sky
the middle does a decent job but like
there's so much flair
everything looks flat covers the whole
photo so the right
yeah pixel 5 pixel the first one for the
pixel
nice whoa okay we got a zoom shot here
okay it's obvious the one in the center
like the left one
oh it's so nice just kidding like you
can't read anything not even the subway
yeah center s20 fe nice
the best zoom right they do a great job
yeah
oh look at that we got a nice wide
portrait shot right here
what do you think once again there's
quite a bit of flaring on these two
i think i have the winner i think i know
but the one the one on the left is
pretty dark
i don't know i'm going with the left
just by all of the detail that's in her
coat right here and there's less flaring
as well like you could just bring it up
in post i mean even now i think it looks
better to me
i kind of like the one in the center so
you went with the iphone 12
i went with pixel 5 another one nice i
like the detail it's nice and bright
like she
pops out like the sun isn't as blown out
like as the other two and the flaring is
not that bad it kind of looks nice
all right another high dynamic range
shots the sun
i'm going with the left me too right
away yeah
iphone 12. all right we have a portrait
shot and
wow this is kind of interesting i'm
really liking the one in the center just
how much blur that has
it's pretty nice the other two are
obviously different
the one on the right is way too like
blown out and bright
yes very cool toned i think it's a very
cool tone the one on the left is pretty
nice
it is kind of nice oh that's hard i like
both of them it's hard because
these are different shots they're very
different but they're both but i mean i
like the center just because of
how much blur there there is looks nice
yeah i kind of like it too
pixel 5 again nice that's a nice shot
it's pretty
all right we got a moon shot and the one
on the left is
what in the world yeah the left is bad
between
the middle and the right i was going to
say the middle but look at all of that
noise that is
that's horrendous i'm going with the
right yeah i agree you sure
okay pixel 5 again that noise is crazy
pretty gross
yeah all right we have a sunset shot
wow the sky pops i like the center you
like the center
yeah yeah if i look closely
i think we're getting more detail
everywhere in the center
and you have a kind of warmer tone
to everything which i think looks better
than especially this looks purple
is this purple yeah i like it though
it's purple i don't know i'm going with
the center i am too but i do like the
one on the right
iphone 12 again all right basically the
same shot but it looks like now we have
the
ultra wide and i don't know based on
this
what do you think i'm definitely not
going with the left one that looks
pretty bad um the one on the right is
more wide
it's more center one looks like it is
this building you see more of it here
and you see three windows as opposed to
two there i think i'm going with the
center because the snow
looks the most accurate it looks very
white as
as well as this building like the colors
actually match to what we see in real
life so i'm going with the center
i don't know why but i kind of like the
right one okay you're going to the right
all right so i got iphone 12 again you
got s20 oh
all right we got night mode what do you
think the one on the right is really
crushed
like all the detail all the trees you
can't see anything that's a good point
all right i'm seeing more detail on the
left and it's not as blown out either
yeah i'm going with the left yeah me too
s20
nice i don't know what the iphone 12 is
doing man it's
pretty bad whoa another nice shot the
one on the right is awful
what do you think i'm instantly going
with the center look at that much more
detail
so much detail in this night shot for
sure
s20 fe man it's killing it all right we
have
a selfie and i think
i mean the one on the right is the only
one where i can actually see
like his beard hairs all that detail as
well
the one of the center's not that bad the
left one's really hard yeah look at that
this
is like a vampire in that one okay right
there's
like artifacting or whatever yeah the
one on the right
s20 again wow those night shots whoa
interesting okay what do you think um
the one on the right
looks so bad in my opinion does it both
of the first two look pretty good
i feel like the one in the center has
the most natural kind of dynamic range
where like the other two look kind of
flat like they try to go
too far and the sky ends up looking kind
of gray instead of a darker sky on the
middle so
middle for me yeah for sure pixel five
there you go that one looks so
good another for the pixels so much
better all right we have what looks to
be an ultra wide
definitely the one in the center you
think the center yeah
i think so too because the medic is you
can actually see the sign
it's not blown out and in general
everything else looks pretty decent as
well
s20 again nice all right so that's the
end of the photos and it looks like we
have 23 of them
go ahead pause this video count up your
tallies
and let us know down in the comments
before you watch this but
lika what'd you get i got 11 for the 12
8 for the fe and four for the pixel
okay so i got 10 for the 12
i have eight for the s20 fe
and five for the pixel so it looks like
our scores are very similar she had one
extra
for the iphone 12 and i had one extra
for the pixel 5
but overall it looks like the iphone 12
is the killer
in this test beating out the other
phones especially beating out the pixel
5 and
i don't know why so many people are
saying it's the king of photography
because
due to our last couple of videos like
the other unbiased comparison
it's gone last place yeah every single
time it's just not doing that well
sorry guys it's 700 and the fe
is also 700 so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video
and if you did go ahead and click the
circle above to subscribe
and check out the other unbiased camera
comparison we did
right over there thank you guys for
watching this has been vadim
and angelica and we'll see you in the
next one